this is human brain tissue inside a rat
brain some scientists think that it
could help with understanding the human
brain in one day even treat conditions
like schizophrenia depression and autism
but this Tech opens up a lot of ethical
questions that green blob is called an
organoid an organoid is a ball of cells
with certain characteristics of an organ
so in this case the brain in lab dishes
brain organoids look like little pearls
researchers study them because they
mimic how human brains develop and how
they work they're grown from a person's
skin cells that then can be engineered
to turn into any kind of cell in the
body and that opens up the door to
potentially being able to develop
specific treatments for specific people
but organoids grown in the lab dish have
their limitations unlike a real living
brain organoids don't have blood vessels
to feed all their cells and that limits
how big and complex they can get they
also don't get information like touch
vision and smell that are real brain
does through our hands eyes and noses
scientists implant organoids into
animals because it allows them to study
brain disease in an environment that's
closer to a normal brain these new
hybrid brains are called chimeras this
recent Stanford study found that neurons
and chimeras grew more than neurons and
organoids see this small Stumpy neuron
that's from an organoid growing in a
dish this one on the left it's from a
chimera and it's way bigger and has far
more branches and this is how neurons
normally look in the brain those
branch-like tentacles make connections
to other neurons and form huge networks
that are at the heart of how the brain
works now this is important because
brain conditions that change these
networks the Stanford teams that using
chimeras help them discover key
differences in cells that make up brain
networks they take organoids made from
cells of patients so the genetic
condition called Timothy syndrome which
is associated with autism and epilepsy
scientists then transplant those
organoids into the brains of baby rats
they found the neurons in these chimeras
had less branching and were smaller than
in chimeras with healthy organoids
remember that neurons and Dish bound
organoids are also less complex without
chimeras the researchers may have missed
this difference this highlights the
advantage of using chimeras for
understanding brain diseases and coming
up with new treatments that's why some
scientists are so excited about brain
chimeras but one big question is whether
human neurons actually hook up to rodent
neurons if they do you'd expect their
activity to affect the animal's behavior
the behavioral output is the ultimate
um proof that the organizer really part
of the entire system the same Stanford
researchers grew organoids with healthy
human neurons that had been tweaked to
have sensors that respond to Blue Light
they flashed pulses of blue light
directly into their chimeric rot brains
through a fiber optic cable this is
important the rats couldn't actually see
the blue light with their eyes the
flashes were literally all in their
heads by pairing the light pulses with a
sip of water the rats learned to expect
a drink whenever the light flashed that
lesson was wired into the human neurons
with the blue light sensors So
eventually when the researchers flash
blue light into those neurons the rats
when looking for water on their own and
what that shows is that the organoid had
become a working part of the animal's
brain the Stanford study only looked at
behavior in animals transplanted with
healthy human organoids The Next Step
will be testing behavior in animals
implanted with organoids from patients
with brain conditions and seeing whether
that's different that kind of
information would get scientists closer
to coming up with better treatments
chimeras are an incredibly useful tool
but they have some limitations first
they are very labor intensive which
makes scaling them up difficult and
animal bodies are not the natural home
for human brain tissue which could
affect how neurons grow and then there's
the big ethical questions like do
chimeras have human-like qualities human
organoids integrate pretty well into
rodent brains especially if the
transplant happens when they're babies
that's when brains are most susceptible
to change so humanized chimeras are a
possibility so far though scientists say
they haven't seen signs of higher
intelligence or other human qualities
and that leads to another important
ethical question could we'd be creating
unintentional suffering without knowing
that we're doing so the Stanford
researchers didn't see signs of memory
loss seizures or increased anxiety but
as in any experiment it's always
possible to miss something important so
basically scientists have to figure out
whether they have to think about
chimeric research more like human
research brain chimeras are only one
example of a growing number of high-tech
and somewhat controversial strategies to
study and combat human diseases that
includes human monkey embryos and pig
organs transplanted into humans
researchers have even restored some
function to dead pig brains with all of
these Society will need to balance the
promise of better therapies with a very
real ethical concerns these Technologies
bring up
foreign